one of the reasons you were the in
charge of the Foodies list is because
you are a legitimate foodie I mean you
love food and you do I've we've all
talked to you about different kinds of
food but this is true one of our our
favorite remotes too involved you going
to Taco Bell headquarters one of my
favorites you were brought there as a as
a gift to you because Kona knew that you
loved it so much yes
um but you got to go to to Mecca to talk
about headquarters in Irvine I think
yeah in Orange County somewhere it was
truly a gift and they have a lab there
they I I kind of famously a test lab
yeah where they're always coming up with
new yes food because you know it's
amazing Mexicans as it turns out don't
know how to make Mexican food you need a
laboratory
get it right right that's what they're
trying to do at Taco Bell that was a
glorious day yeah it like literally I
felt like
man they come off my whole life led
to this moment
yeah like this this is it man you
manifested that yeah yeah this is it
this is what you did all the hard work
Dancing Yeah
Yeah you swallowed your pride right and
you made it here I could really see that
to be part of this wonderful thing uh
yeah I felt I manifested the Dorito Loco
Taco I swear I thought about that thing
really is that what you tried when you
were down there the Doritos no no this
is okay I'm just saying I have you have
a little bit of a synchronicity with
Taco Bell yeah I would say so yeah
absolutely I would have if I was you and
loving Taco Bell shooting the remote I
would have tried to make friends with
everyone who worked there and so you
could call up and put them on the food
back down yes have you ever been back it
was overwhelming it'll say you know
hindsight you go
how did you prepare your body for that
remote had you done a cleanse or like go
really hungry that body at that time was
Taco Bell already
preparation yeah if you stay ready you
don't have to get ready
yes that body was Taco Bell
that body was Taco Bell optimized yeah
yeah you were the band for the job yeah
yeah what a day yeah is there stuff you
ate that didn't end up in there like
were you just
getting to gorge on all these different
things or was it kind of a limited was
it mostly focused online there are
definitely things it's cool because you
can go in there yeah and I don't know if
it's still the same but they encourage
you to to try new things I think it's
part of their job they can just be
sitting at their desk and go you know
what I feel like a such and such you
know I feel like a quesadilla stuff with
steak and chicken and sour cream
whatever yeah
yes they're all on the Foodies list yeah
because you were eating I remember that
I was like wow you're they would seem
like regular employees right there right
trying the food out it seems like they
can just get up anytime and just go hit
that kitchen up yes very definitely an
advantage to working there slip your
resume under yeah someone's door yeah I
just remember thinking like I zoned off
during it like and like what am I
doing yeah do I go back yeah is this
real we are actually outside of the
sensory panel this is where we have
employees come and they test our food I
love this place
well you have a job okay
okay do you ever like go now when you're
in Taco Bell or you're like yeah I've
been to headquarters no not once no no
no no
yeah yeah 12th floor oh you're so cute
thinking Taco Bell has salsa they don't
know I mean it's salsa ask hot sauce we
talked about this the other day because
yeah I love Taco Bell I think I've
always loved pepper once
that's insane to me in life like my
entire life and you can't even remember
when it was so it might not have ever
happened no idea I don't know how does
that happen how does what how do you
avoid Taco
choice right
it just finds you well living in New
York there were no Taco Bells yeah and
then I come out here and then it was
like
um well you come out here and it's like
there's great Mexican food out here so
I think like you said you have to try to
avoid Taco Bell I don't even know where
one is you tell me where there's a Taco
Bell around here close to here yeah when
you put it like when you put it like
that's my case okay yeah I guess there's
not I worked well between your house and
the big Studio the case closed we're on
a road trip you wriggled your way out of
that one the moment you leave La you're
you're just flooded with Taco Bell right
I don't I don't stop when I'm okay well
yeah you don't eat I don't you know that
just I do know I know you don't eat
between meals yeah
I love Taco Bell I'm a huge fan of their
whole
just ethos I think yes they're so what
is their ether when you say they're
ethos I know I want to understand I
don't know it's there's an aesthetic
there's a like a it's a little bit
ironic it's a little bit retro they they
just I feel like they experiment with
great flavors they do and it's a
maximalist
place all right more is more okay yeah
but they don't have salsa
I wouldn't say they technically they
have sauces and they do they have
sausages
considered a salsa ish now I want to go
I mean it's ironic food it is a little
bit ironic okay it's it's a little bit
of a uh you come down there smiling yeah
yeah yeah you think about how many ways
Taco Bell
has flipped what maybe five or six
ingredients yes because it's that's
right we have either corn tortilla flour
tortillas right tomatoes right beans
right beef
yeah there's not that many they're
always working with that palette yeah
and they can put them in so many
different sour cream sometimes and it
makes a huge difference so if you're
going from crunchy into soft or soft and
crunchy or all soft or you do you know
what I mean yeah they work with textures
yeah a lot of texture okay this sounds
great speaking of texture play I really
still I can't believe they haven't
brought back the double decker taco and
I'm manifesting that I was a I was a
double decker it'll happen for you okay
thank you you know why it'll happen
because they brought they brought the
Mexican pizza but they have and they
brought back the enchiladas but if you
wish yeah the enchiritos right yeah and
if you wish for it hard enough it can
happen wait isn't that just two Taco
soft taco a layer of beans and then a
hard shell taco yes and yes and beef
that's the yeah that's the textural but
Taco Bell also you know really well they
make everything its own contained
package the vessel is also edible okay
which is really nice in your car